WE'RE JOINED BY OUR PANEL OF
FORMER WHITE HOUSE INSIDERS,
OLIVIA TROYE, ALYSSA GRIFFIN
AND STEPHANIE GRISHAM.
STEPHANIE, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
THE SCENE WHERE DONALD TRUMP
WAS TAPING VIDEO MESSAGES TO
HIS SUPPORTERS.
AND THEY WERE OUTTAKES, HE
CAN'T SAY THAT, OR I DON'T WANT
TO SAY THE ELECTIONS OVER, THAT
MUST OF RUN THROUGH FOR YOU,
I'M GUESSING.
>> YES, I SAW THAT SHOW MANY
MANY TIMES.
TONIGHT MAY BE SAD AND IT MAY
BE DISCUSSED IT ALL OVER AGAIN,
BUT ACTUALLY, NOTHING SURPRISED
ME.
DONALD TRUMP AS ALL OF US KNOW
HERE, HE WILL NOT APOLOGIZE AND
HE WILL NOT ADMIT DEFEAT.
AND I THINK THOSE OUTTAKES
REALLY SHOWED THAT, REALLY
SHOWED BUT HE WAS LIKE.
AND I THINK IF I COULD SAY
ANYTHING, I CANNOT ECHO LIZ
CHENEY'S WORDS ENOUGH, AS TO
SAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WERE
DUPED BY HIM.
I WAS DUPED BY HIM.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
HE CARES ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> YEAH, IT'S INTERESTING WHEN
HE SAID THAT HE USED, HE
WEAPONIZED THE PATRIOTISM OF
HIS SUPPORTERS.
ALYSSA, YOU KNOW SARAH MATTHEWS,
THE DEPUTY WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY WHO TESTIFIED.
AND THERE WAS A VERY
INTERESTING MOMENT WHEN SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH
THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT
CALLING OFF THE MOB AND HIS
BIZARRE CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
DOING THAT WOULD MAKE HIM SEEM
WEAK, WOULD GIVE HIM A VICTORY
TO THE MEDIA.
LET'S ROLL SOME OF THAT.
>> I COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT WE
WERE ARGUING OVER THIS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WEST WING,
TALKING ABOUT THE POLITICS OF A
TWEET, BEING CONCERNED WITH
HANDING THE MEDIA A WIN, WHEN
WE HAD JUST WATCHED ALL OF THAT
VIOLENCE UNFOLD AT THE CAPITOL.
AND SO, I MOTIONED UP AT THE TV,
AND I SAID, DO YOU THINK IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE EFFING WINNING?
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT DOES.
>> AND JUST, WHAT A MASTERFUL
LINE BY SARAH, BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY EVEN WORSE THAN HOW
YOU DESCRIBE IT.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION ABOUT
AIDS IN THE PRESS OFFERING
OFFICE.
KAYLEIGH MCENANY HAD ALREADY
COME FROM THE OVAL OFFICE
TRYING TO GET TRUMP TO SAY
SOMETHING.
HE SHE CAME BACK AND WHISPERED,
HE DOESN'T WANT TO SAY STAND
DOWN.
AND THEN THE AIDS AMONG
THEMSELVES ARE ARGUING, WHETHER
THEY SHOULD SAY SOMETHING MORE
FORCEFUL, AND THE SENSE OF MANY
OF THE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE ROOM,
INCLUDING, I IMAGINE, THE WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY WAS, WILL
LOOK LIKE WE'RE WINNING AND
GIVING A WIN TO THE MEDIA IF WE
COME OUT AND CONDEMN THIS
WHATEVER WAS TELLING US TO.
I THINK WITH A DID MASTERFULLY
TODAY, WAS GET INTO INTO THE
PSYCHOLOGY OF THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE AND THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM,
WHICH WAS NEVER ADMIT DEFEAT,
NEVER ADMIT FAULT, AND MAKE
SURE YOU INSULATE THIS MAN WHO
FEELS LIKE A CONSTANT VICTIM IN
EVERY SCENARIO.
AND THAT LINE WILL STAND OUT TO
ME, ERIC HERSCHMANN SAYING, WE
WERE ALL DRAINED.
AT 4:15 IN THE AFTERNOON,
CALLING IT A DAY IN THE WEST
WING, WHEN ON CAPITOL HILL,
THERE STILL A RIOT AND
INSURRECTION TO TAKING PLACE.
JUST A PATHETIC SHOWING ALL
AROUND FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T
SPEAK OUT.
>> YEAH, NO, IT WAS INTERESTING
FROM ONE OF THE POLICE MEN WHO
WERE ON THE CAPITOL THAT DAY
WHO COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT ERIC
KIRTZMAN WAS SAYING THAT THEY
FELT DRAINED, HE SAID SOMETHING,
LET ME SEE IF I CAN FIND IT
HERE, HE SAID SOMETHING LIKE,
YOU FELT DRAINED?
LIKE HOW DO YOU THINK WE FELT?
I'M PARAPHRASING POORLY ALSO.
OLIVIA, YOU ARE UP THERE
WATCHING THE TESTIMONY, I SAW
YOU SITTING WITH THE OFFICERS.
JUST A REMINDER VIEWERS, YOU
ARE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
TO VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, WHAT
WAS IT LIKE FOR YOU TO HEAR A
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL WHO WORKS
IN THE SECURITY FIELD WHO IS
GIVEN ANONYMITY, TALK ABOUT HOW
THE CROWD WAS CHANTING, HANG
MIKE PENCE.
THEY WERE COMING FOR HIM.
THEY WERE LITERALLY COMING FOR
MIKE PENCE.
AND SECRET SERVICE AGENTS,
PEOPLE ON THE VICE PRESIDENTS
DETAIL, WE'RE CALLING THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THEY MIGHT NOT MAKE IT
HOME.
>> LOOK, I'M NOT GONNA LIE, I
GOT VERY EMOTIONAL IN THE
HEARING.
I WAS FIGHTING BACK TEARS.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE IT WAS TEARS
OF SADNESS THAT THIS HAD
HAPPENED, IN OUR COUNTRY, AND
THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT'S LIFE
IS PUT AT RISK.
BUT IT WAS ANGER AS WELL.
I WAS SO ANGRY IN THAT MOMENT,
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING TO
MYSELF, THIS IS ALL BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
DIRECTLY IMPLICATED BECAUSE OF
HIM.
AND TO HEAR THE SECRET SERVICE
PEOPLE, THEY WERE SAYING, I
THINK THERE ARE SAYING GOODBYE
TO THEIR FAMILIES.
AND ALSO, I CAN'T IMAGINE,
KNOWING THEM, HAVING TRAVELED
WITH HIM AND HOW MUCH PRIDE
THEY HAD IN THAT JOB, KNOWING
THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT IS THE
PERSON THEY'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT IN THE MOMENT, AND THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE LOSING.
THEY'RE LOSING HOLDING THE LINE
WHILE PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
CAPITOL, THOSE OFFICERS, ARE
DOING THEIR BEST TO FEND OFF
THIS MOB, AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
THE SCENARIO THAT WE SAW
FIRSTHAND, HOW CHILLING THAT
MOMENT WAS.
I THINK THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR AMERICANS TO HAVE
HEARD THAT FROM THE SECRET
SERVICE THEMSELVES TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE I REALLY THINK THAT
THAT GETS TO THIS ENTIRE, THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK, THE
INCREDIBLE IMPORTANCE OF IT,
AND WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THESE FACTS OUT THERE BECAUSE
PEOPLE KNOW THIS IS NOT A SHAM.
THIS IS A REALLY DARK DAY IN
HISTORY, THAT REALLY, WE JUST
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND CUT
ACCOUNTABILITY NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
>> DO YOU THINK, STEPHANIE,
THIS IS GOING TO CHANGE ANY
REPUBLICAN MINDS.
WHETHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING ALONG WITH
THIS HORRIBLE CHARADE FOR SO
LONG, OR JUST REPUBLICAN VOTERS
OUT THERE, IS IT GOING TO HAVE
AN IMPACT?
>> I HAVE TO BELIEVE IT WILL.
I THINK FOR SURE IT WILL HAVE
AN IMPACT ON INDEPENDENCE.
I THINK THAT'S WHO WE NEED TO
BE TALKING TO IN REACHING.
BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP'S BASE,
WE'RE NOT GONNA CHANGE THEIR
MIND.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE AMERICANS WHO MAY
NOT WANT TO SAY IT OUT LOUD,
BUT WHO WILL GO INTO THE VOTING
BOOTH, KNOWING THAT THEIR
PRESIDENT SAT AND WATCHED TV
FOR THREE HOURS WHILE PEOPLE
WERE FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE OF THE MOB
THAT HE SIPPED ON THEM.
WE SHOULD NOTE, WE WERE TALKING
EARLIER, THAT WHILE THE
TESTIMONY WAS GOING ON, SOME
TROLL WHO WORKS FOR THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE, WHO
WORKED FOR CONGRESSMAN ELISE
STEFANIK, PERSONALLY ATTACKED
SARAH MATTHEWS WHILE SHE WAS
UNDER OATH, TELLING THE TRUTH.
SAID SOMETHING NASTY ABOUT HER.
THE TWEET WAS EVENTUALLY
DELETED, YOU CALLED IT OUT,
OTHER PEOPLE CALLED IT OUT ON
TWITTER.
THE TWEET ULTIMATELY WAS
DELETED.
BUT THIS IS A SMALL TASTE OF
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE COME
FORWARD AND CRITICIZE DONALD
TRUMP.
>> YES.
IT WAS INDICATIVE OF, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON HAS DEALT WITH THIS,
SARAH MATTHEWS WILL, YOU HAVE.
>> YES I HAVE.
>> IT WAS PARTICULARLY SHAMEFUL
COMING FROM ELISE STEFANIK'S
HOUSE GOP TWITTER ACCOUNT.
THIS IS A WOMAN, WHO AT ONE
POINT I ADMIRED, THAT
CHAMPIONED YOUNG WOMEN, TRIES
TO GET MORE REPUBLICAN WOMEN
ELECTED.
YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN HOUSE
STAFFER IN SARAH MATTHEWS WHOSE
UNDER OATH, WHEN SO MANY MEN,
TWICE HER AGE, WILL NOT GO
UNDER OATH AND TESTIFY.
AND THEY'RE PERSONALLY
ATTACKING HER, CALLING HER UPON
AND I THINK A LIAR, AND TRYING
TO UNDERMINE HER.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS SHAMEFUL.
THEY DID THE RIGHT THING AND
TAKING IT DOWN, BUT I WAS VERY
HEARTENED BY HOW MANY PEOPLE
CAME TO SARAH MATTHEWS DEFENSE.
SHE HAD AN IMPECCABLE
REPUTATION WITH THE CAPITOL
HILL PRESS CORPS AND --
PEOPLE ARE COMING OUT OF THE
WOODWORTH.
LIKE WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS ABOVE
REPROACH AND DOING THE RIGHT
THING WHEN OTHERS WON'T.
>> I HOPE THE DELETION OF THAT
TWEET US SOME SORT OF SIDE
ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN CONGRESS, BUT
I HAVE TO SAY, I'M NOT HOLDING
MY BREATH.